Even though technically Objective-C
is a statically typed language,
it sneaks in more flexibility in
typing through the use of the type ID.
ID as you'll remember is like
saying to be determined or
this object can be of any type.
At runtime a more specific
type is determined.
Delegates generally have type ID as
well as objects inside of arrays.
When Swift is consuming
Objective-C code,
objects of type id are given
the type any object.
An object of type any object
can hold a variety of types.
Although your code may work if
you allow objects of type ID
to be imported as objects of type any
object., it's not really in the spirit
of Swift development to allow for
such flexible types.
Not to mention,
any object can leave you vulnerable to
unrecognized selector errors when
you're dealing with untyped arrays.
Let's take a look at an example.
Here's a Backpack class
written in Objective- C.
And you can see it has a property called
Keys which holds an NSMutableArray.
This example project also has a class
called Key which implements the method
openDoor.
Here's some Swift Code that's
using the Backpack class.
First, we instantiate
a Backpack instantiated
Key to represent her house key and
then add that key to the backpack.
So far so good, now let's take
the Key out of the Backpack and
try to open the door.
The code above compiles fine but
when we press run we've got a problem.
So, let's go down to the console and
see if we can see what's going on.
We have to scroll up to the top.
Okay,what have we got.
Unrecognized selectors sent to
instants and a bunch of numbers.
What's this about a string.
If we look again at
the Backpack class we can see
the first object in
the array as an API key.
So, it doesn't implement
the method openDoor.
OpenDoor is the unrecognized selector.